So at some point or another,
you will be looking most likely for a prop firm to use.
Now, for those of you who don't know,
and assuming many of you do know,
a prop firm is a company that allows you to trade
up to $400,000 of capital,
and you're able to take anywhere between 70 and 90%
of the profits that you make.
I mean, if you have $100,000 from them,
you make 10% in that month, you make $10,000 minus 20% fee,
and then you're left with the 80% of that,
which is the $8,000, and that would be your payout.
And you can actually get $100,000 in capital
for just $497, and all you have to do to do that
is pass a prop firm evaluation.
There's one prop firm that I will recommend to you,
and there's a couple of others that are still legitimate
out there that will pay out and things of that nature,
but for the purposes of this video,
I'll be sharing with you alpha capital.
Alpha capital is a prop firm that I personally use.
I'm not a huge fan of prop firms,
and when I could move to personal capital,
that was always the goal for me.
Many of the members at some point in time
were asking what prop firm should we go for?
What prop firm should we go for?
And I've been wrong in the past.
I thought that at some point,
my forex funds are the good prop firm.
I thought that there was another firm,
they're an old friend of mine created,
and I was wrong on that one as well.
And so I was like, you know,
I'm prop firms just like they're a no-go,
they're just a mess, they all fall apart.
Regardless, members needed a prop firm.
And so I went out to figure out
which prop firm was actually worth using.
And alpha capital, one of the top three that I would recommend.
I have personal relationships with the owners
and leaders inside of alpha, which I like.
I like having people on the ground
that I can personally talk to.
I have multiple six figures in funding with alpha.
I've never been rejected the payout.
I've never had trading issues in general.
My experience has been pleasant.
I've been with them for months and months and months
as I've recorded this and had zero issues.
That's something that I'm super proud to say.
And it was only after testing them myself
that I was able to bring them to the community.
Alpha capital, the prop firm that I would recommend
that you start with, you could also go with an FTMO.
For example, only FTMO do have some stricter restrictions
and they don't operate in all countries.
So make sure that you're able to do your due diligence
regardless of just this video.
But a quick kind of overview of alpha
and kind of how it works.
So alpha have both alpha capital.
They also have alpha futures
and they also have their actual own broker.
So that's always a massive benefit.
They've been operational for a long time.
They are one of, if not the only prop firm in this sense,
the kind of retail prop firm that have been audited
by the FCA and actually have a valid license
from the FCA, the Financial Conduct Authority
in the United Kingdom.
That's a very, very, very valuable document in this game.
That means that they are authorized to operate
as the way they're operating.
It's very unlikely that this prop firm
would get shut down or something like that,
which gives you massive level of confidence.
They're run by some pretty heavy hitters
that have had a large and long career
in financial markets, in brokerages, hedge funds
and real prop firms.
I say real prop firms because you have to understand
the model of prop firms.
There is a conflict of interest at the beginning
because a real prop firm is a firm that you will trade for
and you will keep a percentage of the profits.
Exactly the same structure.
The only difference is that the most of the time,
these retail prop firms, these demo prop firms,
they're not actually put in your life capital
into the market.
Oftentimes they're even be booking your accounts.
There's a whole story that I could run through on that
but I'll save that for another day.
It's not really that important.
What is important is that at some point in time
if you show consistent profitability
over extended periods of time,
you will actually get abooked,
meaning that they will actually put your positions
into the life market and oftentimes back them
with real capital, making you an actual prop firm trader.
But that's also come in the future.
It's just part of their risk precaution.
I mean, if I owned a company and I knew that in the industry,
the product that I sold, it solves a massive problem.
I can't be responsible for traders taking challenges
when they're not ready and failing them.
That business model just exists.
Alpha Capital are doing a great thing
because they provide people like yourself,
the opportunity to trade hundreds of thousands of dollars
in capital that you wouldn't have otherwise
being able to access.
By understanding that 90% of traders
who take these challenges fail,
that's how they make their money.
There's no hiding that.
They pay your profits out of the money that they make.
But if people want to take challenges
when they're not ready, that's on them.
That's their own learning curve.
We need people like that
because if people didn't take prop firm challenges
when they weren't ready,
you wouldn't have prop firms to trade that's on them.
So just make sure that you're actually trading
prop firm challenges and stuff when you are ready
so that you're not just wasting money unnecessarily,
which a lot of people do.
They think that if they just pass a prop firm,
then it'll solve all their problems
and they'll start making money.
And that's not how the game works.
Why Alpha Capital?
Again, like I've said, I've personally used them,
had a great experience, had many payout,
never had any problems.
This is pretty much what they have.
So this is how it works.
They have a couple of different approaches
and what I really like about these days
is you can actually customize how you want to plan.
This is kind of what we have.
Swing trading accounts, we have Alpha One,
which is a one-step evaluation.
And then you have Alpha Pro.
Alpha Pro are the accounts that I personally have,
the two-step Evo.
I don't like the one-steps.
There's a lot of tricky technicals that go inside.
The one-step accounts, for example,
a lot of them have Freiland drawdowns.
So these have a max drawdown of 6%.
By the way, you can absolutely go 6% into drawdown.
In fact, I had a prop firm account
that I was 9% in drawdown.
So 10% that I lose the account.
I got 9% in drawdown.
I climb myself all the way out of drawdown and into profit.
You can get to 9% drawdown.
What this 6% does is it limits you and restricts your risk.
You don't want to be trading with a 1% risk
when you've only got 6% max drawdown
because you only have six trades
and you could go in a six-trade losing streak.
I don't like the one-steps for that purpose.
Maybe you can customize it and get more of a drawdown.
The problem is that this is what most people go for
because it's easy, easy, always comes at a price.
What I personally like to have is the Alpha Pro,
which is actually two-step.
And then you can customize, you can go anywhere
from $5,000, which you could get for just $50,
or up to $200,000, which is $1,000.
You can also add some add-ons as well.
What I like to do is, which just makes sense,
I'm gonna get a two-step Alpha Pro,
and I personally do want to go for $200K.
The 10% target is $997.
The 8% is $1,000, $97.
So an extra $100, I will pay,
and I can return 2% less than what I need to.
That's ideal for me because I know
that there's a very high chance
that I would pass that challenge.
It makes sense to pay the extra $100
to only need 2% less.
And then platform is up to use.
You've got C-trade, you've got DX-trade,
and you've got MC5, it doesn't really make a difference.
You can obviously don't need to go with the 200K,
you can customize it with whatever accounts that you want.
If it's your first prop firm,
I recommend going for,
depending on how much you can afford to spend,
I recommend pretty much going anything
from 50K to 200K.
A 5K, like $77, is that really gonna affect you?
Not really, right?
The problem is, if you go in there with a 5K account,
the numbers that are fluctuating on your MC5 account
when you're in a trade are so small,
especially what you've used to compare to demo, right?
Many of you've been testing on a demo on a 200K
or a 400K or a million dollar demo,
and now I'm sending you on this 5K account
and the profits look so small, the losses look so small,
that can really dent your psychology.
In a number of ways, number one,
what that can do is you cannot care about it,
so that actually might help you trade better
because you don't care about the money,
you actually don't have any emotional resistance attached to it
because it's like $77, do I care if I lose this?
No, that's not reality.
The reality is if you wanna be a trader
who's managing 200K, 400K, a million dollars,
then you're not getting the real experience
of what it's gonna be like to have real money under your belt.
So if you've already proved to yourself
that you can be profitably in back testing,
sure, you could go over 5K just to show
that you can do it in the live market,
but the truth is you already can do it in the live market.
It starts to become difficult when emotions get in the way.
So the other negative drawback of going with a 5K
is like if you pass that 5K, you're like,
"Oh man, I'll just go for a 200K."
And then you go for a 200K and all of a sudden,
the size of the profits are just so much bigger,
it's like what, 40X, so that shocks the system
and that can be actually more detrimental psychologically
because you can start getting those emotions more tense
because everything is relative.
So now you've seen 40 times the difference
where you're used to just losing here, this or winning this.
Now it's 40 times more intense,
which can definitely have psychological implications.
And also potential, another kind of drawback is
you don't really care about losing the challenge.
So if it's $77, who cares, if you lose the account,
it doesn't bother you.
And that doesn't really give you the progress
of what it is to be a real trader
because your goal should be never to blow an account.
You should have that level of risk management.
Putting yourself in an environment
where you're only trading this amount of capital
probably sets you up, not the greatest.
So I would recommend for your first account,
go from anything to 50K to 200K,
depending on what makes sense for you financially.
I highly doubt if you're in this program,
even if you're on a 10% a $300
prop firm account isn't gonna be that much of a big deal.
Let's be real.
A 200K account for most of your game
probably won't be that much of a big deal.
Let's be honest.
I'm assuming most of you won't,
but if you only have $1,000 in your savings account
and you could only pay to pay check,
or you only have $3,000 in your savings account, for example,
risking 30% of all you have
when you've never passed a prop firm time before,
that may create a necessary stress
and kind of hinder your process, which has pros and cons.
Pros of it are the more intense
that the psychological reactions are,
the more difficult it is to control.
If you do it right, the better control
you will get over yourself.
So that's possibly a pro.
There's many different angles you could look at it.
This is the thing, like everybody's always asking me,
what should I do?
What account should I take?
How much risk should I have?
And it all comes down to you personally.
I don't know you as well as you hopefully know yourself.
So I am always giving you content.
You don't want to risk not enough to the point
where it doesn't matter.
And you don't get that psychological hit of battle,
which will happen.
And not too much so that it's so intense
that you can't actually afford to lose this challenge,
or you can't actually afford to lose that money
that you deposit into your broker account,
because that will create implication.
The three step as well.
So the three step is cheaper.
Three step is pretty much 8%, 4%, 4%, right?
So whereas two step, you can get it down to 8%, 5%.
This is three step and it's 8, 4, 4.
So there is an extra step.
It is cheaper, but honestly, I don't like the drawdown.
Can you add more drawdown?
No, I'd probably avoid that as well.
The best option is going for the two step.
It gives you actual 10% drawdown on both.
So you have 10% to play with,
which is really important if you want to risk 1%,
or maybe you want to risk 0.5%,
still that 10% buffer is important.
The max daily drawdown, 5% should never be going over that.
That will be from going completely until.
Leverage isn't really important.
One to 100, one to 30, one to 20,
doesn't make a difference if you're applying proper risk
management.
And then obviously at checkout,
you can enter the coupon codes that I'll leave
in the description below.
You'll get, I think it's like 20% or 30% off
or something like that.
You can use that if you would like to.
Obviously you have this.
The thing is if you are a US resident or citizen,
you can't use alpha cap proper.
I'm not sure which prop firms are allowed in the US.
I do know futures prop firms are allowed in the US.
And so alpha also has alpha futures,
which I'll break down in a different video,
but you can access alpha futures or any futures prop firm.
And then you can technically trade 6E, right?
So you can trade euro USD futures.
If you are a US resident or citizen
and alpha cap doesn't work for you,
you could look at alpha futures
or try to find a prop firm that does allow US citizens.
I think pretty much most CFD 4X prop firms don't allow US.
So you have to trade futures,
but you can trade euro USD futures and without any difference.
So that's definitely an option for you.
That's pretty much all I have to say about alpha.
That's what I would go with.
That's my thought process.
I've also had a great experience.
You can also take a swing trade account as well.
If you would like to hold trades,
I think you can hold trades over the weekend
on the swing account.
I think you can hold them through news as well.
If you need for whatever reason to hold through news
or over the weekend because you're a swing trader,
then yeah, go to the swing as well.
But yeah, alpha pro is the one that I would recommend the most.
Good drawdown, two step.
I would go for 8% profit target,
even if it is a little bit more expensive.
Pretty much what I have to say about alpha cap
and prop firms in general, to be honest with you.